Jeff Jackson just apologize for voting to ban TikTok.
I apologize in case anyone's behind this guy.
Jeff Jackson used TikTok to get elected,
and then when it came time to vote on the TikTok ban,
Jeff voted yes.
Well now he is apologizing for that yes vote,
and he sort of explains why he voted yes.
According to him,
there was a briefing that is not available to be seen by the public,
and whatever was shown during this briefing caused Jeff some concern,
which caused Jeff to vote in favor of a TikTok ban.
Now, based on the comments of Jeff's apology video,
it still seems like nobody is on Jeff's side,
as when he was asked a specific question in the comments,
Jeff said quote, I don't know,
which upset people
because he doesn't really seem to know much about the Bill,
yet he voted yes to ban TikTok without having all of the information.
There's also people accusing him of taking money from a pack,
which I can explain what that is.
Let me know if you want.
It's a whole other video though.
But right now it just seems like despite the apology,
people still are not going to trust Jeff Jackson.